CHEF JOHN HIGGINS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
YOU KNOW, THE QUEEN WAS BELOVED
BY SO MANY PEOPLE.
THERE ARE VERY FEW WHO CAN SAY
THEY ACTUALLY GOT TO DANCE WITH
HER.
GIVE US YOUR MEMORIES.
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS
EVENING.
>> FIRST OF ALL, JOHN, GOOD
YOU KNOW, LIVING AT BUCKINGHAM
PALACE WAS THE MOST INCREDIBLE
EXPERIENCE I'VE EVER HAD IN MY
LIFE.
SOMETIMES YOU LOOK FROM THE
OUTSIDE AND WONDER WHAT IT'S
LIKE INSIDE, WELL, I EVENTUALLY
GOT THERE AND NEEDLESS TO SAY, I
G
GOT TO SEE THE INNER SANCTUM OF
HER LIFE.
I WAS VERY PRIVILEGED IN A LOT
OF WAYS TO TRAVEL WITH THE ROYAL
FAMILY TO THEIR DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS, WHETHER IT WAS
BALMORAL CASTLE, WINDSOR CASTLE,
OR MY FAVORITE WAS UP IN
SCOTLAND TO BALMORAL.
AND I WAS VERY FORTUNATE TO DO
EVERY YEAR TO DO THE GILLY'S
BALL, IT'S SCOTTISH COUNTRY
DANCING AND VERY HAPPY TO SAY I
ACTUALLY GOT TO DO SCOTTISH
COUNTRY DANCING WITH THE QUEEN,
THE ROYAL PRINCESS AND THE ROYAL
FAMILY.
AND YOU CAN DEFINITELY TELL WITH
THIS ACCENT, I'M A LITTLE BIT
SCOTTISH, BUT NOT A GREAT
COUNTRY SCOTTIC DANCER.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS,
THEY MADE ME FEEL AT EASE AND
VERY RELAXED AND IT WAS A
GRACIOUS EVENING, AND SOMETHING
I WILL NEVER, EVER FORGET.
>> THOSE ARE CERTAINLY BRAGGING
RIGHTS, AS WE MIGHT DESCRIBE IT
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, TO
HAVE HAD THAT KIND OF
EXPERIENCE.
WHAT WAS SHE LIKE AND DID YOU
HAVE ANY DOS AND DON'TS WHEN IT
CAME TO COOKING FOR THE QUEEN?
>> YEAH, VERY GRACIOUS, VERY
GRACIOUS LADY, VERY RESPECTFUL.
AND COOKING WAS, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE SAY, WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
WELL, VERY SIMPLE.
JUST GREAT PRODUCT, COOKED VERY
SIMPLY WITH A LOT OF GOOD
TECHNIQUE AND LET THE FOOD DO
THE TALKING.
THERE WAS ONE THING, DID YOU
EVER GET ANYTHING SENT BACK FROM
THE QUEEN?
NO, NO, REALLY, APART FROM ONE
LITTLE TIME I COOKED THE FOOD
FOR THE CORGIS AND THE ROYAL
DOGS AND YOU COOKED THE HEIR AR
AND RABBITS IN A SAVORY BROTH.
I PUT IT THROUGH THE MEAT
GRINDER AND THE FOOD CAME BACK
HALF AN HOUR LATER, AND IT WAS,
LET'S GO BACK TO THE WAY WE WERE
DOING IT BEFORE.
THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
SO TRADITION WITH THE FOOD.
EVEN FOR THE DOGS, EVEN IN
TODAY'S WORLD, I COOK FOR MY TWO
DOGS WITH THE SAME PASSION AS I
COOK FOR DOGS COMING TO MY
HOUSE.
IT'S SIMPLE THINGS, TREAT
EVERYONE EQUALLY, EVEN THE ROYAL
DOGS.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, THOSE ARE
SOME LUCKY DOGS.
AND YOU GOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET PRINCES WILLIAM AND HARRY
BACK WHEN THEY WERE YOUNG BOYS
WITH PRINCESS DIANA.
I JUST WONDER, WHAT'S IT LIKE,
CHEF, WHEN YOU WATCH THE FOOTAGE
NOW AND THE WAY THESE YOUNG BOYS
BECAME MEN.
WHAT'S THAT EXPERIENCE BEEN LIKE
FOR YOU, HAVING KNOWN THIS
FAMILY FAIRLY WELL.
>> YEAH, IT WAS MORE -- I GOT TO
MEET PRINCESS DI.
THE KIDS WERE AFTER I CAME BACK
TO THE STATES.
BUT JUST LOOKING FROM AFAR AND
LISTENING TO THE STAFF, I WAS
STILL IN CONTACT WITH THE
PALACE, IT'S BEEN AN EVOLUTION.
LIFE HAS CHANGED.
YOU THINK OF THE TECHNOLOGY HAS
CHANGED, THE WHOLE ROYAL FAMILY
HAS CHANGED.
AND I THINK IT'S -- I ALWAYS
SAY, IT'S RESPECTING THE
TRADITION, BUT EMBRACING THE
FUTURE.
DEFINITELY, THE WORLD HAS TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN IN ALL OF THOSE
YEARS, BUT THE GLUE THAT'S KEPT
THE WHOLE ROYAL FAMILY, AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED, HAS BEEN
DEFINITELY THE QUEEN.
SO IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
IN THE NEXT 10 TO 15 YEARS, HOW
THE FAMILY EVOLVES.
AS WE SAY IN THE COOKING WORLD,
LEARNING IS THE MAIN INGREDIENT.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW IT HAPPENS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE MIGHT BE A LITTLE TRIAL
AND ERROR, I WOULD SAY, IN THE
DAYS AHEAD.
CHEF JOHN HIGGINS --
>> NOTHING'S PERFECT.
>> NOTHING IS PERFECT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
CHEF, THANKS SO MUCH.
AND IT'S WHAT YOU MAKE OF IT, AS
YOU KNOW, AS A CHEF.
THANK YOU, JOHN HIGGINS, VERY
MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> TAKE CARE.